¿Qué estamos viendo en esta foto?
Esta es mi querida esferera, se llamaba Raquel de Soltero Rubinstein.
Se casó con un gran personaje, se llamaba León.
Cuando llaman para la Torá, lo llaman León Allen.
Era una persona querida en su ciudad y muy conocida.
¿Cómo puso esta foto?
Esta foto fue cuando era joven, ya casado, con cuatro hijos, cuatro varones y una hija
que mi querida esposa llamaba Estela Weintraub.
¿En dónde fue tomada esta foto?
Esta foto fue tomada en Varsovia. Mi esposa se casó en Varsovia.
Ellas estaban tres hermanas en Varsovia y dos murieron en crematorios y uno se fue para Israel.
¿Por qué motivo fue hermana de ella para Israel?
La hermana de ella era muy rica, muy, muy, muy rica.
Que dos hijos con toda riqueza eran comunistas y llevaron a ella para cárcel.
Ella se sacó de cárcel y toda la familia se fue para Israel.
Se fueron para Israel, hicieron su casita.
Cuando fui un socio de ellos, de 36 socios que yo compré toda esa riqueza, se llamaba Kirshenbaum,
él la dio, esta hermana millonaria, con su esposo millonario, un gran hombre educado,
ladrillo a ladrillo hicieron su sola trabajando con su casa.
¿Quiénes están en la foto?
Mi hermano mayor Pinchas Reis Sobol se casó en el año 26.
¿Quién es la señora?
La señora se llama Mirla Reis de Schneiderman.
¿Dónde se casaron?
Casaron en Polonia en 1926.
¿Cómo se usó esa foto?
Esa foto, ellos tienen aquí en Caracas tres hijos y un hijo.
Y esa foto me entregó una hija de ellos.
¿Cómo se llaman hijos?
Mi hermano, la mayor se llama Dora Reis.
Usted hizo una entrevista, ¿cómo se llama el esposo de ella?
Isaac.
Sí.
La segunda se llama Lola Schockländer.
Tiene dos hijas y un hijo.
La tercero es varón, se llama en nombre de mi papá, Samuel Reis de Schneiderman.
Y última hija se llama Esther Reis de Schneiderman.
¿Quiénes están en la foto?
En esta foto está el señor Reis Sobol.
Y en esta foto está mi querida señora Estela Reis de Weinstock.
¿Y quién es la niña?
Y la niña, Anna Reis, que se llama por mi mamá.
Un año.
Estamos ahorita aquí, estamos en un sitio cerquita de Varsovia.
Como mujer devotada para Varsovia, al lado hay un gran bosque que se llama Otwock.
Allá yo saco a mi señora, que descansa poquito de todos los viajes que hizo, lejos, mil kilómetros,
devotada a la noche.
Ella teniendo aquí 25 años.
¿Cuántos años fue tomada esta foto?
Esta foto fue tomada el sábado, sábado, te voy a decir, sábado de Otwock, en el año 45.
¿Quiénes están en la foto?
Esta es mi querida señora que descansa, que está en paz.
¿Cómo se llama?
Estela Reis de Weinstock y con mi hija, Anita Reis.
Y última hija de mi hermano, Estel Reis de Schneiderman.
¿Y al lado hay dos niñas? ¿La que está abajo es su esposa, quién es?
No sé.
Ah, sí, ya lo he mirado. Está mi hija, Giselita Reis de Lerner.
Pues yo tenía ese lado al ojo, para ver.
¿Y en qué año fue tomada esta foto?
Esta foto fue tomada en el año 49.
¿Dónde?
Valencia.
¿Quiénes están en la foto?
Mi querida señora que descansa en paz y con señor Reis, su abuelo.
Y al lado, no sé quién es.
¿En dónde fue tomada esta foto?
Valencia, en una fiesta.
¿En qué año?
En el año, parece que el 51.
En Londres.
¿Quiénes están en la foto?
La foto está el señor Reis Abol y mi querida hija, Sonia Malca.
¿Quién es el señor Reis Abol?
El padre de Sonia Malca.
¿Usted?
Yo.
¿En qué año?
Padre, este fue en año, un momentico, no sé, 16, estoy destruido un poquito.
Hay en esto, hay 22 años y medio.
Cuando ella fue especializarse con su marido en Londres.
Allá estuvo, allá, con cariño como se sienta, mire, y hablamos de todo, que habla una hija querida con su padre.
Yitzik Mayagas, con su querida señora, y no se pueden decir muchas palabras, era una mujer, muy educada,
y ella dio su todo cariño para sus hijas.
Era tan educada, cuando ella dijo algo a sus hijas, nunca le dijo lo que yo le dije,
ella dijo, soy papá.
Siempre me mantenía jefe de la casa.
Ella era más jefe que yo.
La educación de ella, siempre, honor me dio, que ella dijo papá.
Tengo muchas palabras que decir, lo cuanto yo puedo decir es poco.
¿En qué año fue tomada esta foto?
Esa foto fue tomada en el año 1984.
¿Dónde?
En Caracas.
Esas otras, mi querida señora, no quiero repetir tantas veces las palabras,
está con mi querida hija mayor, Anita Rice.
De soltera de mi señora, viene de Rubenstein.
Y Anita Rice, estaba casada también con un exposo, también se llamaba Rubenstein.
Hija mayor, mi señora tenía mucho cariño, de mí no hay que hablar.
Y es, era cariño, y es cariño, y se queda con cariño.
Y que Dios, da a ella mucho suerte la vida.
¿En qué año fue tomada esta foto?
Esa foto fue tomada, me parece, no estoy seguro, en primer mes de...